24會
略經綠數字領域
高話得成果中關係呈現發展的良好這符合雙方利益和人民期待雙
關發展的當今世界經歷百年未有局
中作為推動多化的量
支持全球化的兩市場
多樣性 的兩
穩定中責任共為世界提供更多穩性為發展提供更多推動力
為全球治理提供更多引領支持
今年是國建立全略 中關新點我們總結歷史經驗
把握世界大事
展現智慧持全略
[Applause]
中略雙關 thank you Mr. President
excellence we would like to
thank you for your hospitality your
welcome on the occasion of this  summit
we are happy to meet you
in person
as you have mentioned in recent
months the European Union and China have
relaunched a number of
high-level dialogues on important topics
such as issues related to
economic development issues
related to  climate and again issues
related to human rights and
today we have the opportunity to
take stock of the state of our
relations and we hope to give
new impetus to this cooperation between
China and the European Union
Last June, the 27 European heads of state and
government held a
strategic debate on the relationship between
the European Union and China and we
are united in being committed to the
pursuit of a stable and
mutually beneficial relationship with China.  a
commitment and a relationship that we
want based on principles of
transparency, predictability and
reciprocity so very naturally
today we will promote our
European values ​​including
human rights and democracy naturally
we will also defend our
legitimate interests and we wish
cooperate with you on
global issues such as climate,
health issues and of course
security and
stability issues the European Union and China
are important
trading partners we wish to establish
sustainable,
balanced and fair trade relations  for more
prosperity for our
respective populations every day more than 2
billion euros of goods are exchanged
between China and the European Union
however the trade deficit
European Union amounts to nearly 400
billion euros we hope that
measures  concrete measures can be
discussed and put in place to
rebalance this relationship in the
current context we believe like you
that the European Union and China have
a responsibility in favor of
peace and stability on the basis of the
principles anchored in the Charter of
Nations  United as we
speak Russia continues
to attack Ukraine and
seriously violate the Charter of Rights the Charter
of the United Nations as well as the
territorial integrity and sovereignty of
Ukraine we wish to be able to
discuss with you on  the best
ways to resolve this situation and
support the principles of
international law finally there is in CE a
tragic war in the MO in the Middle East
Hamas has brutally attacked the people
of Israel we condemn this attack
we support the right to  Israel to
defend itself must be done in accordance
with international law and according to the
principle of proportionality the
humanitarian situation in Gaza is
disastrous we wish to be engaged
to provide humanitarian aid and
to support a political solution of
peace based on two states of peace  and
stability are important in everything we
hope that we can cooperate to
encourage Iran and the tools not to
provoke a regional escalation we
are also attentive to the situation in
Asia we are concerned by the
growing tensions in the
Taiwan Strait and  in the South China Sea
and as you know we
are opposed to any
unilateral attempt to modify the Coo status
by force or coition and we
maintain our position of
recognition of the One China police uh
finally very quickly we wish to
continue to cooperate with  you for
climate change for health on
a global level for
food security the relationship between the
European Union and China is a
broad and mature relationship we wish to
demonstrate frankness of transparency of
respect we hope that this summit will be
the  opportunity to give
new impetus to our relationship on the
bilateral level but also our
commitment on the international level, I
thank you
[Applause]
thank you very much Mr President for the
very warm welcome yesterday I had the
pleasure and the honor to be at the
Temple of Heaven a strong symbol for the
longevity of Chinese tradition and
Chinese history and it's a pleasure to
see you again and to be here in China
for the second time
this this speaks for the importance the
Europe
relationship we have m trade US 23 billion
euros  a day and important investment
stakes in each other's economies and as
major powers in the world the European
Union and China have global
responsibilities we have a shared
interest in peace and security in the
effective functioning of the rules based
international order
and to find solution
to and this  to end to the Russian
aggression against Ukraine and establish
a just and lasting peace consistent with
the un charter and in the same way to work
for a to do everything possible to work
for a two state solution in the Middle
East how we can man our relation and
sign ecic
a on the prosperity and security of our
people at times our
interest and when they do not we need to
add and responsibly manage the concerns
that we have this is why icome
the
b relship China is eu trading partner
but there are clear imbalan and
differences that we must add we both
recognize the importance ofisking and
strengthening the resilience of our
economies and that is why the Europe
Union is
workingrastruct technological and
industrial bas we will discuss how to
continueeration onimate change and on
how to increase our cooperation on
global rules for  artificial intelligence
and our teams have held several dialogs
in the past few months on climate on
trade on digital issues i propose that
we hold our people to people dialog very
soon the
and our di human
are disc and di usar iden respective
positions I'm now  looking forward to our
discussions and I'm looking forward to
making real progress thank
you